there is a shorting of staffing inside
nevada hospitals this is another reason
why keeping track of our coven 19
numbers is so very important
the i-team's vanessa murphy joins us now
live with those details vanessa
yeah there's a shortage of healthcare
workers in nevada and also specifically
a shortage
of nurses and hospital staff is working
overtime
and hospitals are actively trying to
recruit
to hire more people according to the
nevada hospital association there was a
shortage before the pandemic and nurses
are needed even more now
while the hospital association's daily
report includes the number of people
hospitalized with covid19
it only lists information by county not
by specific hospital taking a look at
the number of staffed beds lincoln
county and churchill counties are
over capacity and here locally clark
county is
81 percent full nye counties at 88
percent full
i've reached out to hospitals in
southern nevada a spokeswoman for
mountain view hospital
says they're doing everything they can
to recruit new nurses and clinical staff
they're sourcing additional nurses
through external agencies
current ratios are within guidelines and
bonuses are offered to staff in high
need areas
for extra shifts worked as well as
sign-on bonuses
a spokesman for umc says they're well
staffed thanks to nurses
and other staff working overtime and a
spokesman for dignity health says
hospitals are constantly adjusting
staffing
and they've gone to great lengths to
hire more staffing including traveling
nurses to care
for a surge in patients so you can see
staffing is an issue another challenge
is
finding more specific information more
numbers
about different hospitals the nevada
hospital association
not providing that information reporting
live vanessa murphy
8 news now